we're finally here I bet you all thought
I'd never get this far that I wouldn't
be about to deliver my review for the
final saga of Dragon Ball GT and to be
perfectly honest neither did I having
not seen the show since it was first
released in the West
over the decades my distaste for the
products our dramatically and while the
show most definitely hasn't been great
or even good for the most part I gotta
be honest it hasn't been all bad either
in fact a large albeit specific chunk of
the story has been decent - pretty good
despite the issues I pointed out here
and there in saying that however most of
it has been as bad as I remembered but I
will bite my tongue until we get through
this one in today's episode we'll be
diving into reviewing and discussing the
UPS the downs and the nostalgia of
Dragon Ball GT s final sugg the
conclusive 17 episodes on the entire
series the shadow dragons saga
okay so to provide some catch-up in
context in the last episode Goku managed
to defeat super Android 17 and in an
attempt to return the earth back to
normal
gathered the Dragon Balls to make a wish
however something isn't quite right all
the way through the last arc or so the
Dragon Balls have been seen with cracks
appearing and chippings covering their
once flawless exterior and when finally
gathered during the final episode of the
last arc something unusual begins to
emerge from the boss
some evil key and a sinister looking
dragon again not a bad setup at all the
premise is interesting and it links the
prior arc with this one very very well
bringing us to episode 1 the episode
opens and Shenron is looking a little
worse for wear he announces that he
won't be the lap dog to anyone anymore
and King Kai begins explaining that the
Dragon Balls have become tainted by
negative energy from overuse at this
point I'm sure King Kai is only being
used for exposition and literally
nothing more Shenron then absorbs the
Dragon Balls and flies off in different
directions as seven separate dragons
because the Dragon Balls have been over
used those monsters were born and
released from within them by developing
the dragon radar and using the balls
flippantly over the last 30 years they
have abused their powers and created
disorder within nature now the earth and
the universe are in peril and that's
pretty much the gist of things this
story is going for goku assumes
responsibility and journeys to fix the
issue in his commute to doing so
disasters begin occurring all over the
world volcanoes avalanches lightning
storms twisters cities being destroyed
that sort of thing each disaster having
its own dragon behind it and as goku is
searching for the dragons he realizes
that he has no idea where he's going and
that's when pen appears from behind him
with gil a functional dragon radar
although i am less than happy with the
tenuous reason pan is being allowed to
tag along together they happen upon a
small area covered in what looks like
sludge shield begins alerting them that
a dragon is nearby and that's when they
have their very first encounter the
setup for this has honestly been great
with plenty of tension building up to
this reveal and episode 2 so it turns
out that this dragon is super weak and
pan begins to take this as an
opportunity to show Goku what she's
really made of dismantling the toad
light dragon with relative ease this
dragon totally took the wind out of my
sails and the tension out of this entire
arc from
and here's a small spoiler it doesn't
get much better than this for a while
this to me at least wasn't the dragon to
start off this search with but whatever
as the fight continues he gains more and
more strength
eventually overpowering pennant it turns
out that there's something up with this
dragon apparently he emits negative
energy causing whomever is nearby
to have its energy sucked from it and so
while he isn't getting any stronger pan
and Goku are most certainly getting
weaker and weaker the more they hang
around him additionally according to
this dragon he was born from a specific
wish made to return with his father to
life meaning each dragon was created by
a specific wish from the past which is
honestly a really nice touch I think
once he finishes explaining this the two
of them are drained of energy and he
hits them with a blast and dumps them
into a poisonous lake and right at the
last second Gil comes out of nowhere to
make the save what a legend but the
attack was an effective leaving guild to
get smacked into the water before pan
and Goku are thrown in but once again
gill saved the day dragging both pan and
Goku into a none polluted part of the
lake using this moment of rest bite a
fully charged Goku and pan take out the
dragon retrieving a fully restored
orange Dragonball episode 3 Goku and pan
are in search of another Dragon Ball
when they arrive in this town eventually
coming across some sort of slime which
apparently has sucked up all the
electricity this is driven out the
townsfolk and that's the premise of this
episode a small dragon then reveals
himself to be the culprit and covers the
two stands in this electric slime to the
dragon surprise Goku and pan get up
relatively unharmed in response to this
he begins gathering all of his slime
growing in size in response to that Goku
goes Super Saiyan 4 but still fails to
stop him the electric slime dragon gets
yet stronger again by sucking the energy
from the power lines growing bigger and
taking a hold of Goku and pan he
literally defeats both of them and when
as he's about to deal the decisive blow
like pure chance it starts to rain
resulting in him sort of
short-circuiting and eventually losing
his life what an awful fight
what an awful ending but at least they
got the five star ball and more
importantly this episode is over next in
this episode we deal with yet another
dragon while closing in on another ball
the gang stumbles upon a village as it
starts raining fish
the town worships this princess figure
as she delivers fish to them or
something some kid has a bad
relationship with his father and it's
very sad and totally worth focusing on
because I care deeply about it where the
hell is the plot oh here it is
keel begins detecting the dragon ball
coming towards them from across the bay
it is a girl and I guess that explains
the whole princess thing apparently this
dragon was created using the panties
wish in the very first arc of Dragon
Ball monster her embarrassment and so
she attacks for whatever reason none of
their attacks seem to touch her however
it turns out that that is just a barrier
she puts up as she is in fact a monster
with a grotesque outer exterior Goku
begins spinning around turning into the
genie from Aladdin I wish I was joking
and starts the battle once again finding
great success but this is short-lived
and soon after is sent flying into a
wall but thanks to a seagull guess I'm
serious Goku and pan find the opening
they needed to wrap up this episode's
Dragon Ball Thanks I hate it next in
this episode they face off against the
ground dragon one that digs in case that
wasn't clear okay so this was getting to
be a tired formula two episodes ago but
now it's honestly putting me to sleep
the dragon they're pursuing doesn't even
want to fight so they spend the entire
first half of this episode just chasing
however it becomes clear that they need
to stop him when he reaches a nearby
town Goku goes super saiyan 4 to save
some civilians and because Goku stopped
the earthquakes destruction which the
mole dragon caused they begin fighting
apparently he was born from the wish
made at the World Martial Arts
Tournament rectifying wasps Vegeta did
the fight finishes like you all know it
well Goku fights with it for a while it
makes a mistake and then loses one thing
that's different this time however is
that the Dragon Ball starts to absorb
ten so that's interesting the Dragon
reemerge is looking more intimidating
having absorbed the young save episode 6
so apparently he had been using this
mole as a host before and now he would
be using pan as the host resulting in a
more powerful dragon I guess Goku right
now needs to defeat him without
destroying pan in the process which
honestly complicates things at the very
least the Dragon knows that Goku won't
fight back to prevent pan and so he
begins destroying the city goku tries to
put up a strong front turning super
saiyan knocking him around however he
soon catches on the Goku has been
holding back intentionally the dragon
begins calling Goku's bluffin as he
continues destroying the city pan from
within the Beast begs Goku to take him
and her out together and eventually he
does with a ten times
kamehameha but not really apparently
Goku's Hartwell's an in it and so the
blast failed to take out the monster
how strong are these guys whatever in a
moment of Eagle on cockiness the dragon
shows pen one last time to Goku who
seizes the moment by Yankees are right
out once pan is freed Goku goes 100% and
destroys the dragon with relative ease
retrieving the Dragon Ball bringing the
episode finally to a close episode 7
almost all of these episodes begin the
exact same way with guild doing his job
alerting the two of them to Dragon Balls
they're nearby and pan getting annoyed
either shouting at him or attacking him
for some unknown reason not only is this
boring scene the same joke land again
and again and again but it also doesn't
endear me to pans character who I really
want to like but back to the episode the
city at they've arrived in is super hot
so I'm guessing that's this one's themed
and yep it sure is the four star dragon
reveals himself and it's the first
design that looks like it was taken
somewhat seriously upon seeing the
dragon pad makes a mad dash to take him
out and with ease the dragon knocks her
out but doesn't do anything further he
wants to have a regular battle with Goku
uninterrupted as they fight humans that
he can momentarily raises by temperature
to the level of the Sun which is quite
hot I'm told but so much of this early
fight is spent with Goku running away
from this guy which seems really out of
character for him I mean yeah he's hot
but through some key blasts at him or
something maybe go out of base form you
have options Goku and eventually he does
making the last 10 minutes feel like
autofilter we then cut to kill as he's
tending to pan went out of nowhere he's
not to decide buy some ice dragon
finally the plot is changing things up
which my sanity is grateful for he looks
the exact same as the force tired dragon
but blue the fight that transpires
between the four star dragon and Goku is
honestly pretty creative utilizing their
environment to change things up the
dragon fires his attack through a lens
to magnify its intensity and Goku has
the great idea to use the tile cane or
solar flare through that very lens
knocking him for a loop
both fighters get up and now it's time
to take things seriously the dragon
sheds his skin to reveal a hotter
exterior and Goku goes Super Saiyan 4 to
end the episode episode 8 you think this
F
so it would cover Super Saiyan 4s battle
against the four star dragon bud dozen
we caught instead to Vegeta who wants to
help but feels like he can't without the
power of Super Saiyan 4 and thus begins
an entire episode flashing back through
Vegeta's story essentially the plot of
this episode is that bulma has found a
way to make the gia is Super Saiyan 4
using a machine which on one hand given
Vegeta story is a nice change of pace
for him consistently Vegeta's fought
against allowing himself to be loved and
to love other people focusing instead on
his own strength and building that up
however now those loved ones can help
him become stronger than he ever could
alone that is a nice thing and I
appreciate that but a machine granting
him that ability feels very at odds with
what Dragon Balls philosophy is and
doesn't feel earned to me now don't get
me wrong I'm not against helping him at
all I mean the gravity chamber was a
nice way for boma to help Vegeta to help
himself but this one just sort of feels
like a free pass as episode 9 then kicks
off so too does the fight between Goku
and the Dragon who seems to have Goku
beat in the speed department but through
the bizarre use of a mirror Goku gets
the jump on him however he gives him a
second chance because he led pango the
fight therefore is reset when suddenly
out of nowhere the ice dragon freezes
Goku's r he begins berating his brother
for being so lose in battle and as goku
dashes to pan side the ice dragon
freezes limb after limb of goku until he
can't move the ice dragon then orders
his brother to finish him off but he
ultimately refuses and unfreezes Goku
who now has his eyes set on taking out
the cold dragon episode 10 and powering
off the ice dragon freezes the entire
city - bren Goku from taking him out he
uses pad as a hostage throwing the child
at Goku who catches his granddaughter
using his back to block the oncoming
attack that's a nice bit of choreography
I think it actually works from a
storytelling perspective - but Goku gets
the upper hand eventually outclassing
the cold-hearted ice dragon getting him
down to his knees begging for his life
he offers the ball to Goku in exchange
before trying to catch Goku once again
off-guard in falling for this
underhanded trick Goku's eyes take the
brunt of the damage resulting in him
being blinded moving in for the final
blow the ice dragon dashes only to be
met with a fist through the
chest beikoku who reveals that he does
not need to see to win and when he most
certainly does
receiving the three star ball while
still unable to see Goku has had to cure
by the fire dragon whom he is now
befriended as the two are about to go
their separate ways the four star dragon
is shot down by a blast revealing the
final one star dragon the main bad guy
of this arc in an effort to protect Goku
once again the four star dragon
sacrifices himself there's one dragon
left and it's the most powerful one and
they begin to fight but remember Goku is
still blind here he never managed to use
the potion the other dragon gave him and
that potion has been destroyed since
then the fight is honestly quite
entertaining with a lot of creative
action set-pieces being implemented at a
fair within the chaos of the battle goku
manages to land his strongest move on
the one star dragon to zero effect
reacting to this the dragon fires back
with an attack of his own leaving goku
handing the lifeless from a building
scaffold episode 11 as he hangs from the
building Goku verts back to his child
form defeated as the one star dragon
drops Goku from the building lifelessly
to meet his doom out of nowhere Gotha
arrives to make this save with uber
Gohan and trunks everyone's there to
support Goku including vidal chichi and
even mr. satan the group begins
instilling their power into Goku but
they are interrupted by the one star
dragon that is now being called Shenron
the dragon targets Gohan first and then
eyes off the rest of them who all gets
saved by Goku at the last second using
Instant Transmission
despite it being a technique he can't
use effectively as a kid convenient but
I digress
Veuve manages to distract them long
enough for Goku to absorb his friends
and family's powers resulting in his
super-powered
super saiyan 4 at this point goku can't
be touched by Shenron despite being
blind after some action that includes
throwing a clock around Goku lands at 10
times kamehameha on shan-rock
and all is right with the world again it
seems but Shenron has survived and
begins absorbing the Dragon Balls one by
one gaining all of their powers episode
12 at this point I want to make known
that I hate this Shenron design with a
burning passion the battle rages on back
and forth Shenron demonstrating that he
can use the other dragons techniques at
this point our hero Goku is pretty low
but he somehow through the power of plot
gets his eyesight back and lands
massive attack on Shenron seemingly
defeating him but again the dragon
recovers using once again another one of
the dragons special techniques healing
his own body despite me being pretty
certain that's not how that particular
dragons ability works also I have no
idea why he isn't using the first
dragons technique you know the one that
sucked the energy out of everything I
mean he'd be winning now if he was but
whatever
so more back and forth continues and
Goku finally gets him restrained looking
to take him out the same way Vegeta did
with boo but out of nowhere Vegeta
interrupts this and using boomers
machine begins transforming into Nazzaro
and eventually Super Saiyan for what
what really impresses me about this
scene is exactly something I actually
criticized in Dragon Ball super in
Dragon Ball GT Vegeta not Goku Vegeta is
the one that brings forth the idea of
fusion and that shows a ton of character
growth episode 13 the two sands fuse
creating Super Saiyan 4 go Gina and
Shenron cannot touch them and Gogeta is
toying with them in really unamusing
ways if I'm being perfectly honest it
gets very old very fast and really sucks
the tension out of what was an episode
that already lacked a lot of tension for
me Shenron gathers all the energy he can
muster into one blast and Gogeta just
picks it away easily
and that's when out of nowhere suddenly
the world becomes normal again
apparently when go Gina kicked the ball
he converted the energy from negative to
positive which okay go Gina then hits
him with a big bang kamehameha releasing
all of the Dragon Balls flux for some
reason this guy still refuses to kick
the bucket and wouldn't you know it the
fusion ends despite it being only ten
minutes and the fusion expires because
of power or something where have I seen
that before
episode 14 okay so Shenron won't let
them fuse again and Goku eats the four
star ball because obviously for a little
while there's a bit of a cat-and-mouse
game going on here Goku Vegeta want to
fuse but Shenron isn't giving them a
chance to why doesn't go could just
teleport somewhere safe with Vegeta to
do it there and I dunno anyway after 20
minutes of being thrown through
buildings they decide to use their after
image technique and once
can become Golgi no it didn't work
because Goku was low of energy they
tried once again leading to Goku
reverting back to base form
he is completely zapped of energy
episode 15 now with Goku as a kid and
Vegeta in Super Saiyan Ford they need to
figure out how to salvage this situation
and that's when they notice Goku has the
force tower ball on his forehead the
force tired dragon thing comes out of
the pole and hits an uncommon blast away
the four star dragon claims to have been
infected by Shenron when he absorbed him
earlier and now fights Vegeta whom he
easily overpowers and is now down for
the count and after knocking Goku to the
curb it seems chances are grim but when
Vegeta rises to his peace he comments
that the four star dragon had been
pulling his punches that's when we
noticed that Shen ron's guard is now
down leaving the perfect opportunity for
the four star dragon to dash in behind
him and restrain him the four star
dragon begins to glow lock him inside
some sort of heat ball I don't know what
would you call it
fireball yeah that's probably better he
self-destructs this fire heat ball
exploding the two of them scouring the
landscape beneath the four star dragon
lands to the floor seemingly victorious
and that's when Shenron emerges from his
carcass like a spiky butterfly from a
chrysalis
I have ok I thought for a second I have
no idea what's happening this show is
bonkers so shchedrin put himself inside
the body of the soup of the four star
dragon and then he burst out again what
he also exploded and that's when Vegeta
drops back to base form two because
enough bad things haven't happened
already and I guess he turns to boomer
who points out that the machine has been
destroyed and therefore can't produce
any more blood slaves to you know power
him up again but little does she know
that she can pull another one out of her
butt super easy because she did that
during the babies Agha
episode 60 there's really no tension for
me at this point
Goku and Vegeta struggling and Shenron
who has now sidelined Vegeta and sent a
blast towards the Earth
Goku now stands holding back the blast
in his base kit form reaffirming to me
that I have no idea how strong anyone in
this show actually is Google manages to
somehow deflect the blast and at this
point I can't help but fret the
characters like Goten
try
and pan have little to nothing to
contribute to this final Feist barely
getting any shine in the story at all
never mind from a dialogue perspective
Vegeta goes until Ament over his planet
being destroyed by Frieza and now this
planet is about to follow the same path
ordering everyone to hop onto a
spaceship with Bulma to survive that
that is the main priority it's a pretty
strong moment for Vegeta charging
headfirst into battle while ordering his
children and Goku's children to someday
avenge them it's a really cool scenario
and to be perfectly honest it would have
been a pretty cool premise for a story
too but perhaps a little too dark for
dragon ball while Vegeta holds him off
trunks and the rest of the kids decide
to help anyway which is a dumb decision
and makes all of their lives useless now
together they attack to no effect and
that's when Goku rises from the rubble
with a spirit bomb the first one of the
series - and this is a pretty cool
visual possibly my favorite looking
spirit bomb in the entire series not
just GT so how about that
Goku uses King Kai to communicate to the
universe and gathers energy from
throughout he throws the bomb and the
fight is over
Goku lies lifeless on the floor and the
Dragon Balls released the original green
dragon Shenron by themselves ending the
episode which brings us to Dragon Ball
GT s final ever episode man it's a doozy
but like the other episodes let's go
through it slowly to figure out how it
works the episode opens as Shenron
unprovoked heals Goku of his injuries
and awakens him Shenron begins
explaining that jutsu there
over-reliance on the balls the earth and
the integrity of the Dragon Balls
themselves had been compromised on more
than one occasion and so announces that
he will be leaving goku quickly
interjects and requests that the
Earthlings that have fallen be brought
back to life not that the earth itself
be fully restored to the way it was just
to bring back the Earthlings to life
explaining that they can all work
together to restore the earth themselves
which honestly for me was a really nice
touch
Shannen agrees and the Earthlings are
brought back the group share a smile and
celebrate the successful wish but that
is almost immediately brought to an
abrupt stop as Shenron ask Goku to come
along with him Goku seems to know where
he's going and says that he'll see
everyone later and as goku flies off in
the back of Shenron he asks if he can
stop at a few places before they leave
for good the first stop is Master
Roshi's home where he is reacquainted
with the Hermit
turtle and his longtime pal Krillin they
shoot the breeze and reminisce over
their old training days when Crillon
says this Goku can see the hurt and
krillen when he says this and with an
unblinking smile he asks if curly would
like to spar for old times sake
allowing curling to land one last punch
building up his confidence before
leaving for good a nice parting gift to
his one-time rival and longtime best
friend the next and final stop Goku
wanted to make was to see piccolo whom
at this time is residing in hell
it seems he's content working as
effectively their security guard while
there which honestly is nice Goku
appears before him requesting to shake
his hand saying these parting words
piccolo confused and distressed over
what's been said tries to find that Goku
is once again God at this point the
episode switches back to the gang on
earth following Goku's departure they
all began going their separate ways but
trunks notices that pan is still staring
up at we're going left
trunks reassures her that the Dragon
Balls will one day return and that they
need to first help ensure that their
strength is enough to protect the earth
and the universe on its own as they
leave pad notices Goku's clothes in the
floor the month Vegeta from outside of
her point of view tells her to hold onto
that last piece of Goku dearly as if to
suggest that Goku was a very important
person worthy of fondly remembering even
for Vegeta with that Goku falls asleep
on the back of Shenron as the Dragon
Balls disappear into the tired sands bot
the scene fades to black as we cut to
the next scene the World Martial Arts
Championships jr. finals match in the
distant future a new spiffy young
announcer begins introducing a fighter
by the name of son Goku it's revealed
that this young boy is a distant
descendant of the son Goku were all
familiar with who along with mr. Stayton
now has a statue commemorating him at
the World Martial Arts Tournament
grounds pan is seemingly at this point
the last remaining character we all know
alive now a doting grandmother of the
young son Goku looking up from the
sidelines as her grandson takes the
stage wearing the same tattered clothes
her grandpa left behind many many years
ago as a cute turn of events Goku
juniors opponent happens to be an
ancestor of Vegeta bearing a striking
resemblance the two began clashing in
dramatic fashion assuming even Super
Saiyan when pan notices something in the
corner of her eye
[Applause]
stupid enemy Goku Vegeta what follows
this is honestly an intensely nostalgic
look back at the journey we have all
shared with Goku through the series as
he walked under the martial arts
tournament grounds the final lines of
the story being goofy cheerful and
gentle that's the son Goku we all loved
this is where the story of Dragonball
ends what an outrageously appropriate
touching and utterly beautiful way to
close the book and what is to millions
and millions of young people and old
throughout the world their childhood
their inspiration and even at times
their friend and if this arc was simply
just this episode I'd have nothing but
fantastic things to say but let's talk
about this arc as a whole before I end
on a positive note I really wanted to
make this Arc two separate videos as
talking about the ending and the act to
me at least feel like two separate
talking points so let's take one before
the other in this video the arc as a
whole had what is to me and probably to
most people who took the time to watch
it a very interesting and fitting
premise for a story within the Dragon
Ball mythos there is absolutely no ver
reliance on the Dragon Balls and to
convince your audience that there are
consequences for that over reliance
isn't the tough sell but the execution
of it felt incredibly formulaic at the
best of times and incredibly boring at
others for me a worry that I had from
the start was that with the premise as
it was an evil dragon emerging forth
from each individual Dragon Ball I
feared that it would just turn into a
monster of the week type format and it
pretty much did at least for a while
five episodes covered the exact same
formula show up in a town you'll alerts
them to a nearby Dragon Ball pad hit
skills for no reason they find the
dragon that's causing trouble to the
city village or town and they defeat it
and then the town is better five
episodes in a row followed this very
predictable boring tired format and it
really hurt the show for me additionally
with a premise and villains as easily
justifiable as these the dragons are
given no motivation at all they are just
evil because they have no reason to be
evil they just are I don't really like
that they don't have an underlying
motivation at all they refer to
themselves as evil which to me just
isn't interesting the final villain for
this story
really
felt lifeless for me like he had no
personality and was a cookie cutter by
the books Dragonball villain simply
there to facilitate big moments for the
heroes to rise to unlike characters like
Vegeta and Frieza who improved the
battles simply by being who they were
additionally his design really didn't do
anything for me I know this is a
subjective thing but it really just felt
more Digimon than Dragonball if that
makes sense
and finally pad I admire Dragon Ball GT
for wanting to and in many cases
successfully achieving a believable and
interesting new character in pad but
they never and I mean never give for
anything worthwhile to do except cause
problems for Goku and Trunks sometimes
in this arc I asked why is pan still
tacking along surely Gohan her father
who was eager to help would have an
issue with his daughter putting her life
at risk like this and not only that she
causes a problem for Goku in literally
every single episode
why is he cool with her being around all
the time now don't get me wrong I love
the idea of pad as a character but a
character needs a reason to be present
and she really doesn't she has a
motivation to be there sure but not a
reason or excuse to be there but that
brings us to the ending which on its own
is the single most fitting and
tear-jerking ending I've ever seen one
that I've seen a great number of times
prior to my watch through of this but
one that also never fails to bring a
tear to my eye
perfectly encapsulating what I love
about Dragon Ball and Goku in a few
simple snapshots at the end it's a
beautiful way to end the series and one
I have never ever forgotten and probably
never will but now I have a question for
you guys next week I have my final
thoughts video on the entire Dragon Ball
GT series as a whole but after that I
have an idea over the last year I've
covered the entire catalog of Dragon
Ball movies and now I have watched
Dragon Ball GT I was thinking that since
Dragon Ball super is two year
anniversary is right around the corner I
would cover each arc of that show the
same way I did this one seeing as I've
never done that with Super before and
and I'll make a video talking about
which series I thought was better and
why Dragon Ball GT vs Dragon Ball super
what do you think leave a comment down
below but that'll do it for this week as
always I've been totally not mark and
thank you so much for watching until we
meet again
[Music]
you